almost got my mom's friend arrested when
i was six years old my mom had a
co-worker that was from indiana i would
drive back and forth between indiana and
illinois for work one of my cousins
lived in indiana so sometimes i would
drive back with him and they would pick
me up there so i could like hang out or
whatever anyways so on the way there
this woman comes up to me at a gas
station mind you my mom's friend is like
an older guy and he's like a chain
smoker like kind of what you think of
when you think of someone that looks
kind of creepy a woman asks me she says
how do you know him mingy being six
years old said i don't know really
didn't know how my mom knew them i just
knew that they knew each other see your
uncle is he your cousin which i just
said no the woman calls the police i
couldn't get a hold of my parents so
they just held him there for a couple
hours did give me a cool teddy bear
though so it was a good day honestly i
did finally get a hold of my parents and
they let him go but